Ian rapport here on the Honda insider
report brought to you by the Honda
summer spectacular event
how have you been he and Rappaport man I
thought you were gonna use kind of the
transition to be also an awesome dude
Ian Rapoport but but you didn't go there
hold on a second now joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show also an awesome dude
Ian Rapoport here in the Honda Insight
report how are you good - I'm great how
are you I am well as Khalil Mack really
on the trade market right now Ian uh he
is being asked about I know that and
that's actually been going on for like
probably four weeks but you know it's
interesting because I think media a lot
of times gets criticized for making
things into bigger into too big of a
deal like I think the media is making
too big of a deal of Teddy Bridgewater's
trade market for instance though what
teams do is when they see okay a guy is
potentially on the block
players unhappy he's great when my one
on my team they call based on all the
times what they read in the media so as
soon as Khalil Mack wasn't showing up
everybody started calling the Raiders
and I've gotten no indication that the
Raiders would even consider a trade I'm
not saying it's like impossible I'm just
saying when they've talked to teams they
have given the impression that that is
not something we would even entertain
and you know if you think about it would
be very hard for this to happen because
obviously he's worth a first-round pick
and more so let's say you give up that
then you also pay him twenty one or
twenty two million dollars a year and
that is hefty and is that really the
most efficient way handle your resources
if your team I think that's probably the
biggest question so why aren't the
Raiders paying Mack and the Rams paying
Aaron Donald is this a related issue in
well I think the Rams are working on it
with Aaron Donald and you know I don't
know when it's going to get done but
they have been working for some time I
think everybody appears to be sort of
going in the same direction and there is
you know some positivity and some
optimism there that it gets done so I
you know I would not be surprised if
Donald happens before the regular season
as far as coil Mack goes you know he
could do his own deal it's not like he
needs to wait for Aaron Donald it might
be easier if Donald sets the template
but I think the other thing with the
Raiders is they would like to you know
just from the Raiders perspective they
would like to see him they'd like to
meet him they'd like to have him meet
the coaches and see what he's like in
their schemes you know I think there's
there's sort of an assumption like he's
a great player so he's going to get
handed a check for you know 21 million
dollars or whatever it is per year and
he probably deserves it but the other
side of the coin is the Raiders would
like to know what they are paying for
and it's an entirely completely new
regime what does happen what is
happening there with how did it go so
south how is it gone
so far apart I mean there's a Monday
night football game between the Rams and
the Raiders that are good is being
played two weeks from from right now
yeah yeah I mean I think what what
happened was it was there were
discussions earlier this offseason you
know Mac showed up last year it was a
good soldier
and then there were discussions earlier
this offseason and my understanding is
they were so far apart that it just did
not make sense to sort of continue
negotiating and you know at this point
there is no current offer on the table
there have not been recent discussions
at all you know and I know there were
sort of a lot made of the fact that John
hasn't talked to him if you're Khalil
Mac like what's there to say you know
it's either put your you know use the
contract offer to state whatever you
want to stay or say or what are we
talking about Ian Rapoport here on the
Rich Eisen show well so one more item on
this is what is the what is the issue
here I know obviously money but is it a
percentage of what these players are
making compared to what elite
quarterbacks are making and what Von
Miller came in at when a couple of years
ago I mean just take me through the nuts
and bolts I've got Tom Condon an hour -
but these are not his clients yeah I
know although I'm sure he would have
some
the key probably has done a couple
multi-million dollar deals similar to
this you know some of it does work off
you know some of it does work off von
miller and i would imagine that you know
any any aaron Donald you know big-time
extension that could become would be
basically working off the von miller
deal costs adjusted for what the recent
cap is and you know all these deals sort
of assumed that the player is the best
player highest-paid player at the
position easy assumption to make
McDonald I believe the Raiders there
with Mac but again like it's just money
that accounts nothing else he and
rapport here on the Rich Eisen show okay
which rookie quarterbacks are starting
week one as you can tell right now I
would say Sam Donald I think that is
that is pretty clear you know that was
that would be one other than that you
know it's hard for me to see where would
actually you know what would actually is
which of these rookies would step in I
think you know Josh Allen certainly had
a moment hadn't had an opportunity
yesterday did not great obviously you
know interesting I was up in Buffalo a
couple days ago and when they they
wanted to judge everything about Josh
Allen in the past with not just this
play but how he handled when he was
named the starter officially everyone's
Texan and hey great job congratulations
you know the Huddle's the meetings the
practices everything and I wouldn't be
surprised if it was simply a okay he's
not he's not quite ready you know so I
would say for me probably just Arnold
right now and the aspect of Carson Wentz
being up in the air right now
to what do you owe Doug Peterson's I
guess frustration does it sound like he
really doesn't have a say in this that
it's just a doctor and he can't control
it and he wants his guy out there but he
also knows he doesn't want to put him
out there if he can get hurt for even
longer I mean
suss out what's going on in Philadelphia
for me right now Ian Rapoport yeah you
know I think there of course is
frustration and I don't know that it's
just the same questions over and over
remember and he's been getting these
questions for months and it takes a
special man like Bill Belichick to you
know it takes a special man to deal with
these week after week after week
and and not get frustrated but I think
some of it is it's out of everyone's
hand and I think they knew it was going
to be a really close call before the
season they knew it was going to go down
to the wire the fact that Carson winch
is not cleared for contact obviously
means he has an uphill battle and
actually be ready for week 1 but on the
other hand you know there was a reason I
didn't really consider any trades for
Nick Foles and this is exactly the
reason by the way the Patriots just
extended a shack basin on a 10-year
extension big move for them there one of
the marquee parts of their offensive
line was that an act was a 10-year
extension or was that five five-year
fifty million five-year ten a year
extension so I guess Brady should be
happy about that
right I mean that sounds like something
you should be happy about he hung up on
EEI today I mean that isn't he's in
postseason form right now yeah so my
sense on the unannounced Guerrero thing
was kind of funny but my sense on that
rich
Gus is you ever had this situation where
like someone is irrationally angry with
you and you're like man this doesn't
make any sense the only way it makes
sense and then you figure out that their
bosses got angry at them so then they
got angry you right I would imagine that
at some point Tom Brady was told like
look was just not we're not gonna get
into it again I'm sure he would like to
talk about it he talked about it plenty
in the past I think right now there's
probably some sort of nudge from
somewhere inside the Patriots facility
like look could we just not talk about
it this year Thanks well I mean the
first time that Brady ended a press
conference on the subject of his trainer
Alex Guerrero and tv12 partner Alex
happened in his first press availability
of training camp when your colleague I
think it was Ben Valen of the of the
Boston Globe connected Guerrero to Julia
and suspension now that right there is a
third rail implication that Brady ended
a press conference over this was just
merely asking hey man he's back on the
plane or he's back on the sidelines are
we cool and that could be basically
handled like yeah everything's fine
we're good you know I'm out here to talk
about the past I mean yeah he's back on
the plane which he is by the way right
but yeah I mean the Ben Ben Bowlin thing
that was a by understand without those
two issues Edelman suspension and
Guerrera are not related at all but I
mean I you're right I can certainly
understand why Brady would be angry with
that implication yeah I really just
think he just like I'm done like I just
I'm not supposed to talk about it I'm
not allowed to talk about it I'm not
going to and you know I read the
transcript from the eye it was like six
questions in a row now I would never
hang up on you for anything rich thank
you what if you asked me six questions
or on something I'm not going to answer
I would at least make some sort of a
angry distorted face at you you know hmm
you're not doing that right now are you
in no comma good thank you
Ian Rapoport a trap sheet here on the
show so when asked the poll question of
Ian before we wrap things up with him
Chris quickly and after week season
preseason week three which team is in
the most trouble cowboys Eagles Bills
dolphins weight started again I had a
notification on my phone to step over
part of your words say what a twenty
what a 21st century thing to say I can't
I could not hear you read the poll
question because a notification came
over my phone there's like the bane of
my existence trying to almost human
conversations on my phone rang three
times and had eleven text message go
ahead okay go for it after pre-season
week three which team in the most
trouble cowboys Eagles bills dolphins
I would say probably bill I mean
yesterday was rough Tango's defense if I
may be good but I didn't know is that
good
I think Calvin be fine I think the
Eagles are going to be you know if
Carson Wentz has not started the season
for week one I still think they're going
to be probably fine and in decent shape
when he comes back yeah I would say I
would say the bills starting Nathan
Peterman who did not beat out Tyra a
teller last year yeah and and you know
on that offensive line you know Cordy
Glenn is on the other sideline because
josh allen is behind it offensive line
in buffalo that is not seemingly
equipped to protect anybody right now
and so I would say that but the Dallas
Cowboys you know appear to be thin at
many spots tight end wide receiver
suddenly now offensive line we're always
wondering what their secondary is gonna
look like they're they don't concern you
right now yeah they really don't I
really think they're gonna be okay I
mean I think dak is gonna be better
certainly better with no Dez Michael
Gallup is gonna be really good people
haven't heard open he's a receiver they
drafted each other like a lot line yeah
when when Travis Frederick gets back and
I was told weeks not months I think
their offensive line will be just as
good as always and Zeke is gonna be
better this year I guess last one for
you so you can go to your texts and
notifications which I don't get to say
to too many people
why is des on sign what's going on
you know and and and with the Browns
having to reach out to others to try and
get him on the phone finally get him
into camp in Cleveland I mean how it
sure looks like
barring any injury maybe maybe
Jacksonville's on the phone to Dez
Bryant right now I don't know based on
Marquis Lee why is he unsigned right now
yeah I mean I think the short answer is
he hasn't reached a deal with Cleveland
I don't get the sense that doors closed
a lot of times deals happen when they
need to which is right before the start
of the season maybe they come together
but I know I mean I know Cleveland
so I don't I do not get the sense the
doors closed but I also don't think the
jaguars are going to be reaching out
just based off strictly off Doug
Berlin's comments Doug morones comments
what do you mean he basically said he's
really comfortable with the receivers
have on the roster just a couple minutes
ago
alrighty thanks for the time brother
we'll chat down the line see you see you
shortly
all right thank you you go that's Ian
Rapoport of the NFL Media Group at rap
sheet the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience